you brought this up and we didn't get
any videos so this is the new video of
uh
mike you know the name what's what's the
area of the new occupied zone and uh
last i checked it was being referred to
as paws
okay so the portland occupied zone would
you care to check in on paws
also a word for people that have the bug
but whatever
let's check it out chas the sequel
is here where jason rants our longtime
chas correspondent seattle radio show
host joins us now with details hey jason
hey
summer of love in seattle to i guess the
winter of disco what's up with his
eyebrows i was going to bring that up
he looks like a poorly rendered ps1
character you know when he said
i was like did he say chase and rants
because it sounds just like chase and
rants
jason rants yeah and he's a radio show
host so you know he i don't have a
heart a show but you know he has a he
probably has a segment called
rants rants i'm obsessed
with his milton berle eyebrows i was
gonna say eugene levy but okay
either one works okay no
yours was better though eugene is a good
one
eugene levy's one of the hairiest men
who ever lived
look what do you want me to do my kid's
sticking his dick in pies i'm not really
sure what you want from me here he's the
[ __ ] hairiest
actor i've ever seen in my life in
portland north portland specifically
it's the red house autonomous zone a
group of
it's called the red house okay maybe it
is uh that's
red house autonomous a rat i'm still
gonna call it paws
activists within the antifa movement
have set up basically a two two and a
half block radius around a house that
was someone says he looks like eddie
munster
he does it's dude i can't stop staring
at them that's the only thing i can look
at
lost or foreclosed does he have like i'm
not trying to be a dick right but
you are okay it's fine but does he have
any friends you know to fix his eyebrows
up
yeah like somebody's calling him groucho
marx
why uh yeah i'll tell you what uh tucker
it's been quite crazy out here in poland
so i guess the winter of discontent in
portland north portland
specifically it's the red house
autonomous
zone a group of activists within the
antifa movement
have set up basically a two two and a
half block radius around a house that
was lost to foreclosure after a two year
battle
the family is black and indigenous and
so the primarily white antifa residents
believe that this is an example
of gentrification wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait they this person lost
their house because it was foreclosed on
and by the way just to point something
out it wasn't lost
because of because when you could
honestly you could be like that's pretty
[ __ ] up man
people losing houses remind me two years
two years
it's been foreclosure i'm not a big real
estate buff but remind me royce
with that blazer what is
sorry go ahead
what is just refresh my memory and what
the term foreclosed
means like when when you own a home and
they foreclose on it
why would that happen it means that
you've been severely delinquent on your
mortgage payments
okay thank you i looked it up i'm not
sure
so they took out a loan they didn't pay
the loan now they just want to keep the
house
correct that's not how it works why look
i trust me i
i don't think there's going to be many
times you're going to hear me or royce
defending banks
no of course not i am not defending the
bank that being said
you made a deal and now it's been under
foreclosure for two years
i think look i hate banks i think this
bank's been
more than patience
[Laughter]
there's no actual evidence that this is
gentrification however there is a lot of
evidence that there's been a lot of
crime going on no it is gentrification
because there's a
family living in the house that aren't
paying for it and if they can get them
out the bank will probably renovate the
home and sell it to
people who will probably pay for it so
it's i don't know
okay people if it's gentrification or
just capitalism but
by the way nobody gentrifies their
neighborhood better than gay people i
know black people go after white people
but gay people gentrify neighborhoods
hardcore
they do they know second best
pelicans like you can [ __ ] about all
you want but live in one of their
neighborhoods it's awesome
not orthodox well no not well no or even
orthodox neighborhood's great as long as
it's not on saturday and as long as
you're
saturday's the only time no because
honestly all my years of like the the
times i've lived in jewish neighborhoods
they they literally like the the term
[ __ ] is no joke
it they they don't even pay attention to
you it's like when you see a cow on a
pasture
you know what i mean they just see you
walk around they don't even see you
so yeah it's kind of yeah they they
[ __ ] trust me i've lived in belle
harbor
uh i lived in bay ridge nice man and
they
dude them are like look are you really
gonna litter on the sidewalk what is
wrong with you
like they're just very they sweep in
front of their own buildings
they don't [ __ ] around of gentrification
there's no actual evidence that this is
gentrification
however there is a lot of evidence that
there's been a lot of crime going on
as the folks refused to leave cops
yesterday tried to
remove them from the home finally
removed them from the home except
they came under assault the officers
from a lot of people who set up camp
there oh so they also assaulted the cops
well yeah it's portland goes without
saying
as they were treated it ended up giving
a lot of room
by the way hey you because you know the
people that we've seen the protest in
portland is mostly white people
you're the ones gentrifying the place
the ones that are fighting for them are
the ones moving in and gentrifying
the place dude the the the whole black
rights movement has been hijacked by
white people and lesbians
and they're just like it's weird right
it's just weird and there's just a bunch
of black guys going
yeah could i when i okay but can i can i
get a chance when
yeah when you're done talking but like
could i see the microphone
he's tyrone's had it hard yeah i could
say tyrone
save your voice tyrone i mean tyrone's
had it hard
my name's derek it's very difficult tyra
how do you say it derek over here has
had it very hard
that's just derek can i they kicked him
out of his house
could i use the microphone to say some
things about i'd rather you did and i
brought it from home
i'm afraid you might steal my microphone
she has a [ __ ] wallet chain on it
come on guys a lot of people who set up
camp there as they were treated it ended
up giving a lot of room to the antiva
protesters to set up a camp
and right now they are barricaded
[ __ ] in the streets
so basically portland each other i mean
why is this even news though
they've got a stockpile of weapons
they've got armed guards they've got
a kitchen ready so they're there for the
long haul
as the portland police department look
at the risk of sounding like uh
hillary clinton can't we just these guys
you know like can't we just it would
just be easier
so they're stockpiling weapons eh
wouldn't it be great like
just look if we're gonna go into this
new era of hell
anyway can't we just can't we just go
for the gusto and say look let's start
[ __ ] civilian targets you can't say
that harrison smith trademarked it but
okay
okay sorry okay thank you paul as the
portland police department are trying to
figure out what exactly they're going to
do but they
are amplifying the urgency of the
messaging saying
you guys do have to leave peacefully
we're not going to put up with this so
we could potentially see action from the
police in the next 24 hours
it's happening because we are putting up
with it you get what you put up with if
you let your kids smoke weed at the
breakfast table they will
that's who's letting their kids smoke
weed at the breakfast table talk her
i made that mistake uh last week jason
and i'll be honest with you my kids
won't stop now
that's crazy
tucker's just tucker's tucker strikes me
as the kind of guy that still wants
every couple of years
like tries to sneak one joint yeah like
somebody'll be like who goes to weed and
it's like it's one of those like dry ass
weed that he takes home from somewhere
and then he's like
tries to just roll one up and blow it
out the window just late at night
yeah tucker's still smoking an ounce he
bought in 2001
that he has like in a safe not even an
ounce a quarter a quarter
it is safe it's in a safe and it's like
you said completely dry
he didn't even want that much then no
when he got it two years ago i was like
i just need to talk i just can't tell
somebody i don't sell less than that
so you're gonna have to buy the full
quarter i'm sorry that's what we have
if you have you've done that like that's
why i always laugh like when you see
those scenes in those movies like where
dad does that and you're like you know
that's the driest shittiest weed in the
world right now they just rolled this
old joint they're like
yeah honey i'm coming out yeah i was
just
i'm coming